for noble and very understandable
reasons we've come to associate maturity
and kindness with a capacity not to give
up on people our heroes and heroines
keep faith with those they love they
don't throw in the towel when trouble
rears its head they put up with the
hardships and friction running away is
this loyalty many things are dispensable
people shouldn't be but this broad and
generous truth can be in danger of
missing out on an important caveat that
health and maturity may also require at
points a subtle capacity to give up on
one or two people not always and
indefinitely to keep giving them the
benefit of the doubt not invariably to
forgive them one more time
not relentlessly to imagine the nice
things they might really really have
meant beneath the thoughtless and unkind
things they actually did and said we
might need occasionally to despair of
someone as the price to pay for keeping
faith with ourselves it's in the lives
of children that we see this inability
to give up on someone take on its
starkest and most regrettable forms by
their nature and circumstance children
can't give up on those entrusted with
looking after them if and when the
latter disappointing or cruel children
present us with troubling examples of
the impulse to keep going at any cost
with a person who offers us love even
when that love is blended with the
darkest or most unhealthy elements even
when beset by emotional neglect coldness
unreliability meanness brusqueness
broken promises to improve and worse
children will think some of the
following maybe they will change the
child places infinite faith in the
capacity of the loved one to evolve in a
desired direction whatever the lack of
outward evidence the child imagines the
caregiver coming to important
realizations rethinking their position
and seeing the light by a form of
magical thinking the child clings to the
idea of the adult
being on the cusp of transforming
themselves into the person they so badly
need them to be
maybe the outward behavior is bad but
inside they're good heaven knows the
outward stuff may not be pretty there
might be shouting stonewalling outright
beastliness but the child holds on to
the notion that where it counts the
adult is good the fundamental truth
about them must be sound the center of
them is sweet touching warm and decent
the child may be the butt of the adults
most vicious moods that they are through
it all always also their most devoted
and fervent defenders maybe the problem
is that I am bad the difficulties can't
be disputed but their origins are up for
grabs and here the child shows a
tragically in intense degree of
imagination yes there is badness around
but that must be because they the child
are ultimately somehow to blame if only
they could be different the adult
wouldn't be so tricky there is one
thought that must be warded off above
all others that the adult might just be
a mean and self-serving mediocrity that
is simply not possible
better to be a monster or a wretch
oneself than to have ended up in the
hands of a parent unworthy of respect no
one and nothing else could be better
children have no options they can't run
away begin again or say they've had
enough
the world isn't broad the best of
childhoods is an open prison therefore
children don't even picture themselves
in other circumstances what is has to be
those who have the most to complain
about often don't even raise their voice
frightening Lee each of these positions
has its adult equivalent in certain
unfulfilling relationships we may have
as much of a skill as the most
unfortunate child probably the child we
once were at the art of justifying why
we're here why we're to blame why
they're innocent and why we cannot move
it is we in particular those
remorselessly skilled not giving up who
need to hear a curious sounding lesson
in being sometimes a little less loyal
we need to hear that surprisingly some
people just don't change that their
characters have been bolted shut through
trauma and there's no chance that they
will ever whatever they may say and
however intensely they promise display
any evolution we need to hear that
surprisingly some people aren't entirely
good and we aren't necessarily the
problem we need to learn to blame and
get annoyed with someone other than
ourselves we need to do something very
strange walk away this is no sign of
cowardice or weakness of character it's
a sign that we have finally learnt to
love ourselves and so place our needs
where these should always have been at
the center of our considerations
deciding whether to stay in or leave a
relationship is one of the trickiest and
most consequential decisions we can face
our stay or leave card game can help us
towards an answer click now to learn
more